a long jump are returning to training
begins at his first session with a
jumper 4 meters then the next session he
jabs 6 meters and it continues to
improve according to this table ok part
1 hmm just asked us to extend this
pattern what's going to happen at job
number 10 and part 2 says in which
session would is jump be and then they
give you this number I think it's 5 11
on 512 again that's that's the question
now what's tricky about this is that if
you need to look at this diner and
vehicle ok what does it mean and how can
i use all of the mathematical language
and ideas to interpret this ok now i
think most of us recognize when you have
a look at this part in here right you're
like oh it's a GP I recognize that and
you say the first term is for and the
ratio between terms is uh huh so that's
fine so we get that this guy here is
kind of like the editor right answers
like there's the 0 term the first term
sector tetra for first second third
whichever when you count ok but then you
look at this guy and you said that's
weird because this is a series secret
such a time but it's not a GP is it
because you like are from here to here
you don't multiply by some number that
gets you from here to here nord you get
the same over from here to here ok so
then you have to think well hold on a
second i'm getting these numbers from
these numbers you see that to get to
this i have to add um this in this right
so I'm actually going to label these i'm
going to go 21 22 23 24 ok so where does
this 6 come from let's get my color this
is actually t1 plus t2 you see that as
well another cultural yeah when you have
a look at the next one you take this
number and then you add whatever the
next improvement is so in fact it's t1
plus t2 plus t3 that's what the seven is
right and by the same logic I'm going to
run that space but this is t 12
23 and the less the most recent
improvement now when you write out in
this way it kind of becomes a little
clearer that the second row the actual
distance he jumps is not forming a GP
it's the sons of this GP does that make
sense it's you know there's that's s2 by
definition that's we're close to that's
s3 that's s4 so therefore we want this
to fit in somewhere around here so we're
solving for is in when the sum of the
series is what we're looking for okay so
here's the way I would have actually
done my working I'd say of SM and I
don't know what kind is this an equals 7
and 511 or 512 right and for myself I
would say I'm solving for him because
the question the wording is in which
session so that's that's what it is okay
and then I say way ha no second I know
all of the bits and pieces that make up
this series I just need to put them into
the sum of a GP formula what is this
opportunity it's going to be let's write
up here a outside of so I can I've got
two forms to choose from here I can
either go on the denominator 1 motors
are or i can go r minus 1 how do you
think about what this ratio is which do
you think is about choice I can't think
or minus R is better so this is a 1
minus R to the N and this is one nervous
yep so I'm going to fit in all my pieces
over here the first time of course is
for right 1 minus now my R is a half
every time so this is a half M by the
way easy mistake to make just writing a
half and then the end people like say or
without em I know what that is and then
the two doesn't get raised so that's on
the Liberator and went denominator ok
cool and that's what this number is for
part of it equal to and all I need to do
from here is just shuffle around the
numbers and get to the hour
right you can see this is for / a half
what's more / a home at eight so i'm
going to divide both sides by 8 that'll
leave me with this let's release Legend
sorry this divided by eight I think it's
this I was reading it let's double check
it um seven is yeah it is okay so
there's our number they're having / 8
and because you can see that n is up in
the power I'm going to have to appeal to
logs in a second so I haven't quite got
there yet i guess i'll subtract 1 from
both sides so if I leave this guy over
here if you subtract one from this
that's 4096 on 4096 so I think that
leaves you with that it's that make
sense I've gone one part I don't have to
worry about these many signs anymore and
this is actually 1 over 2 to the N do
you agree with that could wonder the end
/ to dinner so that tells me this so now
I mean I could just do this on my
calculator but if I wanted to do it
properly I would say n is log base 2
basically the same or 4096 which i think
is you 12 okay so i think what was high
about this question is it was all in the
phrasing it was like I know all of these
formulas I think once we all got to hear
well it's fine so Deb heal but it's like
working out where is this hiding inside
here okay